طلب مفوض السياسات الخارجيه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي جو سبورت للنادول الاتحاد ستبدا
نهايه الشهر الجاري بتدريب 15 الف جنديا
اوكرانيه
على الاقل اعتمد القرار بشانها والاتفاق
والتطبيق في وقت سريع هو ربما الاسرع لنا
الاتحاد الاوروبي وامل ان يبدا العمل بها
مع نهايه الشهر الدول الاعضاء كذلك ناقشت
مقدار الدعم العسكري الذي نقدمه وهذا
سيناقش بالتفصيل في اجتماع وزراء الدفاع
الى جانب ثلاثه مليارات قدمناها من خلال
الاتحاد الاوروبي
اضافه على جيوش الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي تحديثه ترساناتها العسكريه بشكل
موحد وجماعي مؤكد من القاره الاوروبيه
تعاني تبعات الحرب في اوكرانيا
هذا واضح بسبب التحديات التي نواجهها
والقاره باكملها تعاني بسبب الحرب في
اوكرانيا ويجب ان نحسن ونزيد سياستنا
الامنيه والدفاعيه سنناقش المراجعه
السنويه بشان الدفاع والوضع الحالي للجيش
الاوروبيه من حيث قدراتنا الحاليه وما
نحتاجها وكيف يمكننا فعل ذلك كي نوفر
الاموال ونتشارك في توفير ما نحتاجوه
عبد الله ما الذي يقدم من تفاصيل حول مهمه
التدريب الاوروبيه للجنود الاوكرانيين
نطاقها
ما يشمله من عدد الجنود والتفاصيل الاخرى
نعم هذه المهمه التي تم الاعلان عنها بشكل
رسمي لاول مره في اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه
الذي عقد قبل شهر تقريبا في لوكسمبورغ
يتوقع ان تدرب ما يقارب من 15000 جندي
اوكراني المكان الرئيسي لهذه المهمه سيكون
في بولندا التي لها حدود مع اوكرانيا بسبب
القرب الجغرافي لكن هوليكس ياسر الخارجيه
اليوم قال ايضا ان هناك دول اخرى مثل
اسبانيا والمانيا وفرنسا ايضا ستقوم
سيقومون بتدريب جنود لكن المركز الرئيسي
سيكون هناك في بولندا التدريب سيكون في
المقام الاول على ما يخص التفاصيل الخاصه
بجمع المعلومات وكذلك
بالخطط الدفاعيه والهجوميه التي يمكن
لاكران الاستفاده منها لكن حتى الان هذه
المهمه لم تبدا بشكل رسمي ايضا حسب
تصريحات بريل هذا الصباح قبل ثلاثه شهور
من الان وان كان يرى ان التوافق عليها تم
في وقت قصير وقياسي بالنسبه للوقت الذي
يستغرقه الاتحاد عاده في التوصل الى
الاتفاق الميزانيه المرصوده لهذه المهمه
التي ستكون مدتها
لثلاث سنوات ايام 150 مليون يورو وستكون
يعني تدار من قبل نائبه مباشره نائب بريل
لشؤون الدفاعيه لكن يبقى حتى الان الاعلان
اكثر عما ستقدمه كل دوله هناك دول بالفعل
في الاتحاد الاوروبي تقوم بتقديم تدريبات
واستشارات للجيش الاوكراني لكن هذه المهمه
التي ستكون تحت نطاق الاتحاد الاوروبي
سيكون اعلى خصوصا فيما ستقدمه الجيوش
الاوروبيه المشاركه من خلال شكل الاسلحه
التي سيتم التدريب عليها هذه المهمه التي
تعتبر الاولى للاتحاد الاوروبي داخل نطاق
القاره الاوروبيه ينتظر ايضا ان يتم
الاعلان عن همم مشاركه ليس فقط مستشار
عسكريين وانما قال لبعض الفرق القتاليه
الاوروبيه في داخل نطاق هذه همم المهمه
التي سيكون عليها في المقام الاول تحديث
الجيش الاكراني بشكل مستمر بما يحتاج من
معلومات وكذلك من قدرات عسكريه ودفاعيه